so you mentioned it there you were you
since the last row you got married yes
yes yes yes Wow a celebrity celebrant
yes Adele got ordained and married us in
her back garden me and Paul and it was
just absolutely amazing and she planned
it all it was absolutely absolutely
perfect the best day of my life and go
and get your license and the woman said
who was marrying you as headed out my
ass she we go it's all in her house in
her back garden and flowers as photos of
our family which I don't know where
she'd got there was a man playing on a
grand piano and she went everything
perfect it was so funny because as she
was doing the vows a lawn mower started
wait she ran there sir I will mow the
lawn myself tomorrow but today it stops
she wanted it perfect this is this is
what adele is like she said even after
that she surprised as she took us to
Vegas to see Celine Dion sing Wow it
she's just an absolute star a superstar
as well in person as everything and
we're there and we sneaked in the back
and there was this quite flamboyant gay
in front of me when you know I can't
stand them because he didn't know she
was behind and he was going slain an
Adele when should I just whisper in his
ear hello it's the most magical daya and
then and she paid for everything
oh I said hey I said I can't you can't
do this letter she went no it's so vile
trick I mean she loves fall and
everything she can absolute stuff and
can afford it lovely gesture let's not
worry about her
[Music]
you